Our ocean.
Nearly 4 billion years old
Self-regulating,
self-healing
the source of all life on earth.
Yet, it is in danger
Threatened by a truly global problem:
Marine pollution
From the remotest Pacific islands
To the bottom of the Mariana Trench
To right here on the beaches of Malta
Oil spills,
ship emissions
industrial waste and pesticides
– all poison vast stretches of water.
10 million tonnes of litter are dumped in the sea every year.
400 kilos per second.
By 2050 our ocean could contain more plastic than fish.
Pollution is destroying marine life.
Plastics alone are killing one million seabirds and 100,000 marine mammals a year.
Microplastics threaten to unhinge whole ecosystems.
These problems don’t stop at sea.
Contaminants such as mercury accumulate in the food chain
Affecting the health of millions of people.
With 80% of marine litter coming from land sources, everyone is responsible.
But the solution is at hand.
And it offers a great opportunity.
Marine pollution costs billions.
Switching to circular economies
could make up for this loss and more
with environmental, economic, and social gains for all.
So to reverse the trend of ever-increasing marine pollution
How can we minimise waste?
How can we prevent plastics from reaching the sea?
How can we stop marine pollution?